buenas noches el presidente pedro
castillo anunciado que se va a someter a
la justicia para aclarar los delitos que
se le incriminan y tras arremeter contra
medios locales por señalar que difunden
lo que él denomina no mentiras y falsas
noticias afirmó que se van a cansar de
buscar pruebas por contra él porque
señaló que sencillamente no las van a
encontrar castigo se dirigió a los
peruanos en el aniversario de este país
pero cumplió 201 años de independencia y
tuvo un mensaje más o menos de una hora
50 minutos en el anuncio inversión por
más de 2 mil millones de dólares en el
sector transportes dijo que se otorgará
bonos a los docentes mejorará las
pensiones para los jubilados y señaló
que tomara medidas para proteger a la
población vulnerable frente al alza de
alimentos y que reacciones ha generado
el mensaje del mandatario
el presidente pedro castillo recibió el
rechazo de congresistas de oposición
quienes le gritaron corrupto mientras se
le estaba hablando al parlamento peruano
y también le exigieron su renuncia
muchos congresistas critican la falta de
una denominan una autocrítica por parte
del gobernante en el balance de su
primer año de gestión y consideran que
el mensaje está desconectado de realidad
de la realidad porque señalan que las
cifras no cuadran con lo que ha
establecido el presidente de los
peruanos por su parte algunos medios de
comunicación señalaron que pedro
castillo habría omitido una parte de su
discurso en el que hace un llamado a los
prófugos de la justicia para que se
entreguen esto fue aprovechado por la
lideresa opositora keiko fujimori quien
lo criticó por este hecho y le pidió que
se retire de la presidencia en realidad
pedro casi no tiene horas muy difíciles
porque su principal colaborador bruno
pacheco que está otorgando pruebas la
fiscalía que lo incriminan en serio la
situación es que está diciendo que se
cobraba por ascensos a los oficiales de
la policía peruana esta situación ha
motivado que el ex ministro de
transportes juan silva esté tratando de
entregarse a la justicia para colaborar
con la fiscalía esto ha sido adelantado
por su abogado vamos a ver cómo
evoluciona esta situación en torno al
presidente de los peruanos francisco con
todo este panorama que se puede esperar
del futuro del castillo a mediano plazo
bueno en realidad como venía diciendo se
le presentan horas difíciles
congresistas de oposición señalaron que
van a esperar a que se instale la nueva
junta del parlamento y a partir de
mañana va a empezar a recolectar firmas
para ver si logran someterlo a un
proceso de vacancia presidencial o
impeachment se requieren 87 votos de los
legisladores hasta el momento no existe
esta cantidad es por eso que se están
presentando un proyecto para reducir la
cifra de 87 a 78 por otro lado en las
investigaciones de la fiscalía están
avanzando y se está mencionando que es
muy probable que la fiscal general de
perú pida a la justicia que se le retire
la inmunidad a pedro castillo y pueda
ser sometido a un proceso de destitución